>>> AND WE ARE BACK WITH MORE OF
JAKE'S INTERVIEW WITH EMMANUEL
MACRON, THE FRENCH PRESIDENT
WEIGHED IN ON THE DELICATE
DIPLOMACY INVOLVING IRAN.
AS WELL AS WHETHER DEMOCRACY IS
IN PERIL HERE IN THE U.S. AND
AROUND THE WORLD.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN REITERATED IN
HIS U.N. SPEECH THAT THE U.S. IS
NOT GOING TO ALLOW IRE RAN TO
WEAPONIZE ITS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
YOU MET WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
IRAN.
BASED ON YOUR CONVERSATIONS,
WHERE DO YOU THINK IRAN IS ON
REVITALIZING ANY SORT OF DUKE
DEAL ASSOCIATION THEY WOULD BE
PREVENTED FROM WEAPONIZING THEIR
NUCLEAR PROGRAM?
>> WE HAVE TWO STEPS.
THE FIRST ONE IS GETTING ACCESS
TO ENRICHED URANIUM WITH
DIFFERENT THRESHOLDS AND HOW TO
PRESENT THAT IT'S EXACTLY AS
STIPULATED.
PUSHED BY THE U.S.
ADMINISTRATION IN 2015.
LEFT BILL THE U.S.
ADMINISTRATION ANOTHER ONE IN
2018.
AND THAT'S EUROPE AND THE
AMERICAN ONE TO RESUME.
I THINK A DEAL IS FEASIBLE.
BUT WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO
FINALIZE IT AS WE GO.
AND WE HAVE NOW TO BE CLEAR THAT
THIS IS THE FINAL AND FINAL
OFFER.
WHAT WE MAKE CLEAR TO PRESIDENT
RISI IS THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
THIS BILL AND WE HAVE SOME
GUARANTEES AND SOME EXISTING
TECHNICAL POINTS AS DEFINED BY
THE INTERNATIONAL AGENCY.
THEY HAVE TO BE FIXED FROM A
TECHNICAL POINT OF VIEW, WITHOUT
ANY POLITICAL INDIFFERENCE.
AND THAT IT'S NOT PART OF IT.
NOW, WE KNOW A VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC FOR THE U.S. DOMESTICALLY.
WE KNOW IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC FOR THE SITUATION OF THE
WHOLE REGION THIS AND THE
NEIGHBORING COUNTRY.
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT IRAN, IT
COULD BE A REASONABLE AND
POSITIVE DEAL, IF THEY ACCEPT
PRECISELY THE PROGRESS THAT
WOULD NORMALIZE THE SITUATION.
AND I'M NOT AN AMBASSADOR, I
CANNOT SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THEM.
>> RIGHT.
>> BUT I THINK THEY HAVE AN
INCREASING THRESHOLD.
AND I THINK THEY HAVE NOW THE
GEOPOLITICAL CONTEXT WHICH IS
THE ONE WE WERE DISCUSSING
ABOUT, SO I THINK HAVING A DEAL
COULD BE A GOOD OPTION.
SO IF YOU CAN CLEAR THAT STAGE,
THAT'S IS IT.
THE DECISION IS ON THE TABLE TO
BE TAKEN OR ABANDONED, THAT'S
GOOD.
WEAPONIZATION OF THIS NUCLEAR
CAPACITY IS A SEPARATE STEP.
AND I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE TO WORK ON WITH THE
WHOLE REGION.
I WAS TO STRESS THE FACT THAT
FOR ME, THE REGION IS OUT OF
PRIORITY.
WE HAVE TO DISCUSS ABOUT
ACTIVITIES.
REGIONAL FRONTS OF IRAN AND WE
HAVE TO EVOLVE UNTIL THE WORK
ALL OF IT.
>> I WANT TO DISCUSS THE TREND
OF POPULISM AND RACISM THAT
WE'RE SEEING ALL OVER THE WORLD
GAINING POWER.
A PARTY FOUNDED BY
ULTRANATIONALIST EXTREMISTS AND
NEO-NAZIS GAINING INTEREST IN
SWEDEN.
ITALY HAS A GROUP OF NEOFASCISTS
LEADING IN THE POLLS.
RIGHT NOW, WE SEE OBVIOUSLY SOME
OF THESE ELEMENTS IN FRANCE.
WE SEE OBVIOUSLY SOME OF THESE
ELEMENTS IN THE UNITED STATES.
HOW WORRIED ARE YOU, SPREADING
THROUGHOUT EUROPE, SPREADING
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD?
>> I THINK WE HAVE INCREASING
DEMOCRACIES, WHAT I WOULD CALL
LIBERAL DEMOCRACIES.
LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
WHY?
BECAUSE, TO BE VERY OPEN IN
DEMOCRACIES, PUT PRESSURE ON
YOUR.
PEOPLE.
ITS COULD DESTABILIZE THEM.
AND IS THIS WHY WE ALWAYS HAVE
TO ARTICULATE THE RESPECT OF
PEOPLE'S WILLINGNESS MIDDLE
CLASS REFERRING TO, AND ALL OF
THE PROGRESS MADE BY THE
DEMOCRACIES WELCOMING DIFFERENT
CULTURES.
THIS IS A MATTER OF BALANCE.
AND IT'S CLEAR DURING THE PAST
TWO YEARS WE HAD AN INCREASING
PRESSURE IN OUR SOCIETY.
AND WE ARE AT THE POINT WHERE IN
OUR DIFFERENT COUNTRIES THERE
IS -- WHAT WILL I WOULD CALL THE
CRISIS OF MIDDLE CLASSES.
THEY CONFRONT IT MARGINALIZED
WEAKENED.
I THINK SOCIAL PLATFORMS BRING
VERY IMPORTANT ROLE.
>> AND THEY'RE NEGATIVE?
>> I MEAN FOR THE BEST AND FOR
THE WORST.
>> YEAH.
>> AT THE VERY BEGINNING, IT'S
THE BEST WAY TO COOPERATE.
TO SOCIAL NETWORKS AND
CORPORATIONS, WE WERE SOME FULL
CONTROVERSY, WE EXTENDED IT.
>> ACCELERATE LIES AND RACISM?
>> THAT.
>> RIGHT.
>> IT'S CLEAR THIS IS A PLATFORM
FOR FAKE NEWS AND CLEARLY THIS
NEW WAY.
AND THIS NEW COLLECTIVE VISION
WHICH IT IS COMPLETELY BREAKING
THE RELATIONSHIP TO PRESUMING
AND TO SCIENCE AND THE BASIS OF
OUR DEMOCRACY.
I THINK THIS IS A SECOND.
AND FIRST, WE HAVE TO DELIVER.
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE, THEY WILL
NOT GO TO EXTREME.
A LOT OF THEM, FOR PEOPLE, FOR
THIS TYPE OF SENTIMENT, WE
DIDN'T FIND THESE GUYS.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND THEY GO TO TRY THEM.
AND BECAUSE OF LACK OF
REFERENCE, AND BECAUSE THEY
UNDERESTIMATE THE FACT THIS IS
OUT OF THE SPECTRUM OF WHAT ARE
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES.
PEOPLE GOING AGAINST ALL
PRINCIPLES.
JUST WE DIDN'T TRY THEM.
SO THIS IS THE ADDITION OF ALL
OF THE SENTIMENT WHICH IS CLEAR.
IT'S A STAKE IN YOUR DEMOCRACY,
AND IT'S A STAKE UNTIL OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT OUR
DEMOCRACY?
>> I'M WORRIED FOR ALL.
I HATE SAYING TO PEOPLE I WORRY
FOR YOU.
>> YOU WORRY AS WELL?
>> AND IT'S SUFFICIENT FOR ME.
I DO BELIEVE WHAT IS AT STAKE IS
WHAT WE BUILT IN THE 18th
CENTURY.
AND FRANCE HAD AN INTERESTING
WAR.
>> I'VE READ SOME HISTORY BOOKS,
I KNOW.
>> I WANT TO SHARE, I'M VERY
PROUD.
>> SURE, SURE.
>> I'M A FRENCH GUY.
>> YOU'RE OUR OLDEST ALLY, OF
COURSE.
>> LET ME SAY THAT WE CREATED
AND INVENTED SOME STUFF.
BUT I WANT TO STRESS THAT THIS
IDEA OF DEMOCRACY WAS BUILT ON
LIBERAL VALUES.
THE INDIVIDUAL IS HIGHEST THAN
EVERYTHING ELSE.
IN FREEDOM AND PROSPERITY FOR
MIDDLE CLASS.
AND THE FACT THAT EACH
GENERATION WILL BETTER THAN THIS
ONE.
AND THIS IS A SORT OF BALANCE
AND INTEGRATION BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENT PEOPLES.
WHEN ONE OF THEM IS AT STAKE,
AND WE HAVE A BIG ISSUE DURING
THE PAST FEW YEARS ABOUT
PROSPERITY FOR MIDDLE CLASSES.
WE HAVE SOME PEOPLE CHALLENGING
THE FACT THAT SEEMED --
IRRATIONAL AND DIFFICULT IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING.
AND WE HAVE A CRISIS IN THE
FUNCTIONING OF O